debatte ums impf tempo die kassen ärzte
fühlen sich benachteiligt weiterhin
gezwungen bei der impfstoffversorgung
ende des afghanistan-einsatzes die usa
wollen bis zum 11 september ihre truppen
abziehen die bundeswehr wird wohl folgen
und aus in der champions league münchens
erfolgs trainer flick deutet erstmals
einen möglichen abschied angelaufen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg den abend schön dass sie
dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann für
den sport ein stück von mir die gute
corona nachricht des tages biontech
pfizer will der eu bis juni 50 millionen
zusätzliche impfdosen liefern die werden
ob dringend gebraucht zwar zieht das
impf tempo langsam an aber vor allem
ampullen von byron tags sind nach wie
vor mangelware
dazu gleich mehr zunächst pablo sie lala
hier über den aktuellen stand in
deutschland sind mittlerweile mehr als
14 millionen menschen einfach gegen
korona geimpft vollständigen impfschutz
nach einer zweiten spritze haben knapp
5,2 millionen das entspricht 62 prozent
der bevölkerung seit 110 tagen wird in
deutschland geimpft die kurve zeigt in
den letzten wochen steigt die zahl der
täglich verabreichten impfdosen deutlich
an
geliefert wurden bislang 22 4 millionen
impfstoff dosen davon 15 vom hersteller
biontech 5,6 von astrazeneca und 1,8 von
mutter nach
auch bei den hausärzten dominiert das
vakzin von biontech allein in dieser
woche werden eine millionen dosen des
mainzer herstellers an die praxen
geliefert in der kommenden woche sollen
es knapp eine halbe million sein
in der letzten aprilwoche sogar 1,16
millionen dosen trotzdem impfen in
deutschland nicht rund die hausärzte
beschweren sich dass sie gerade von
biontech nicht genug bekommen dass die
impfzentren viel besser versorgt werden
dazu kommt die große unsicherheit
über den impfstoffen von astrazeneca und
johnson & johnson wegen möglicher
thrombose risiken und das bringt auch
den impfplan durcheinander
volker check hat mehr im
niedersächsischen aurich ist astrazeneca
seit tagen ein ladenhüter
schuld daran sicher die diskussion über
mögliche gesundheitsgefahren pro tag
sagen im impfzentrum bis zu 100 menschen
den vereinbarten termin wieder ab die
akzeptanz ist in den vergangenen wochen
doch weil deutlich gesunken und der
beratungsbedarf in jedem fall gestiegen
und wir haben auch mehrere fälle die
sich vor ort gegen eine impfung mit
astra wenig entscheiden auch hier wird
geimpft doch hier ist die nachfrage groß
die niedergelassenen ärzte sind das
zweite standbein der impfstrategie und
klagen über zu wenige impfdosen wie dr
udo beckenbauer in münchen
er vermisst allerdings
planungssicherheit bei seinem neuen im
job bin ich sicher welchen impfstoff ich
bekomme ich bin ich sicher war nicht
hinbekomme bekomme ich rechtzeitig die
zweitimpfung das ist alles nicht klar
erst die diskussion über mögliche
gefahren durch astrazeneca jetzt der
vorübergehende impfstoff von johnson &
johnson der gesamte im plan wackeln zehn
millionen dosen fehlen vorerst
immunologen fordern jetzt ein schnelles
handeln der bundesregierung wir können
bis in den herbst nicht genügend leute
schützen wenn wir diese einschränkung
auch bei johnson johnson bekommen und
von daher müssen wir jetzt aktiv werden
und uns noch zusätzliche dosen von mrr
impfstoffen für deutschland sichern ich
würde dafür plädieren dass wir das in
einem alleingang machen dass wir nicht
auf die eu warten weil ich dann die
gefahr sehe dass wir wieder zu spät dran
sind marion kaiser und moderner werden
mehr und mehr zum hoffnungsträger vor
allem seitdem die gesundheitsminister
der länder der empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission gefolgt sind die unter 60
jährigen beim zweiten mal nicht wieder
mit astrazeneca sondern mit einem der
beiden anderen vakzine zu impfen
zudem hat die eu heute angekündigt 50
millionen weitere dosen biontech
einzukaufen
das bedeutet für deutschland 9 millionen
dosen mehr bis ende juni ein kleiner
lichtblick
die korona zahlen werden nach der
osterzeit langsam wieder belastbarer und
sie steigen deutlich
das robert-koch-institut registriert
innerhalb von 24 stunden 21 1693
neuinfektionen
342 menschen starben in verbindung mit
coop 19
auch die sieben tage inzidenz nimmt zu
und beträgt 153,2 diese entwicklung hat
direkte folgen für die intensivstationen
dort steigt die zahl der kogit 19
erkrankten wieder seit gut einem monat
aktuell sind es 4680 und es gibt immer
weniger freie intensivbetten in einigen
ländern sind mehr als 90 prozent belegt
auch im saarland verena garrett über
schicksale hinter den zahn
er sitzt und er atmet 134 tage war ich
halt groß an der eco
sie ersetzt die lunge wird mit
schwerstem verlauf seit einem tag lebt
er ohne die maschine
bei der therapie gibt es oft
lebensgefährliche komplikationen nur
jeder zweite überlebt der 57-jährige war
viele tage wach und hat die schwere
seiner erkrankung bewusst erlebt doch da
braucht es schon
ich weiß nicht eine wahnsinnige kraft um
das so ertragen zu können der mann der
hier liegt ist unter 60 seine lungen und
sein kreislauf haben versagt die hohe
sterblichkeit der patienten setzt allem
im team zu
das ist ihre normalität an mir dann hat
man schon irgendwo das gefühl das war
alles umsonst auch wenn es das nicht war
nur weil es war ja schon der berechtigte
versuch jemanden zu retten
und das muss man auch bis zum ende
versucht ob der mann es schaffen wird
weiß niemand das durchschnittsalter auf
der station liegt bei 55
die patienten werden mehr und sie werden
jünger neun betten sind belegt 7 sind
noch frei das kann sich schnell ändern
aber gerade haben sie etwas luft das
liegt zum einen daran dass wir patienten
verlegen konnten
das liegt aber auch daran dass patienten
verstorben sind
weil das eben leider gottes die realität
dieser erkrankung ist seit einem jahr
kämpfen sie hier um das leben der kogit
erkrankten dritte welle ein ende ist
nicht in sicht
der verfassungsschutz in berlin hat
einzelne gruppierungen der querdenken
bewegung als verdachtsfall eingestuft
laut innensenator geisel seien sie
verfassungsfeindlich und müssen
beobachtet werden
die mehrheit der demonstranten gegen die
korona beschränkungen sei aber friedlich
auch in baden-württemberg und bayern
beobachtet der verfassungsschutz
sogenannte querdenken gruppierungen in
der noch ungelösten k-frage in der union
söder oder lasche drängen
unionspolitiker auf eine rasche
entscheidung bundesinnenminister
seehofer csu sagte er hoffe dass beide
eine konsensorientierte lösung finden
gestern hatten sich csu chef markus
söder und der cdu vorsitzende armin
laschet den fragen der unions
bundestagsabgeordneten bestellt
bis ende der woche hieß es wollen sie
gemeinsam entscheiden
der kanzlerkandidat wird theo koll in
berlin wie es stand der dinge wer hat im
moment die besseren karten nun trümpfe
haben beide bewerber in der hand sind
sich aber nicht einig welcher stärker
sticht laschet hat die spitzengremien
der cdu hinter sich so wieder dafür die
mehrheit der fraktion und die umfragen
des laschet lager unterstellt so dass
zusätzlich eine gezähmte karte dass er
nämlich die cdu-gremien unterstützung
für laschet einfach nicht als
ausreichend breite unterstützung
anerkennt es rächt sich jetzt dass die
union für solche machtspiele eigentlich
keine festgelegten spielregeln hat die
folge heute ist völlige ratlosigkeit
einvernehmlich und ohne groll wollen die
beiden kandidaten sich einigen keiner
soll beschädigt werden kann das noch
gelingen
ich glaube nicht ich glaube der zug ist
abgefahren natürlich wird man sich am
ende unter haken und die gemeinsamkeit
die union betonen aber alleine der blick
auf lasche zeigt ja wie groß der schaden
sein wird wenn er verzichtet dann ist er
auch als cdu-vorsitzender angeschlagen
und die cdu-spitze in ihrem votum
überrollt worden aber selbst wenn er
kanzlerkandidat wird dann ist er durch
das gestrige meinungsbild in der
fraktion ja massiv geschwächt und hat
erwartbar 1 markus söder hinter sich der
immer wieder ausstrahlen dürfte dass es
mit ihm er dann doch besser gelaufen
wäre also es gibt im leben angenehmer
lagen als die aktuelle von armin laschet
präzise beschreibung vielen dank berlin
bei der nato in brüssel geht es heute um
afghanistan
seit 20 jahren ist sie dort im einsatz
jetzt hat us-präsident beiden
angekündigt seine truppen bis zum 11
september abzuziehen
an der mission in afghanistan sind 36
länder beteiligt aktuell mit etwa 10.000
soldaten die meisten stellen weiterhin
die usa mit derzeit 2500 männern und
frauen
auch die bundeswehr ist noch vor ort mit
rund 1.100 kräften tom pollock berichtet
seit ende 2001 unterstützen die
soldatinnen und soldaten der bundeswehr
die nato einsatz in afghanistan
nachdem die usa angekündigt haben ihre
truppen bis zum 11 september abzuziehen
dürfte es auch für die deutschen bald
auf heimreise gehen die
verteidigungsministerin erwartet
jedenfalls dass die nato den abzug
zustimmt wir haben immer gesagt wir
gehen gemeinsam reihen wir gehen
gemeinsam raus ich stehe für einen
geordneten abzug und deswegen gehe ich
davon aus dass wir das heute so
beschließen werden außenminister maris
berät in brüssel mit seinen nato
kollegen darüber deutschland unter
anderem mitglieder hätten sich vor dem
ende des einsatzes erfolge bei
friedensgesprächen zwischen den taliban
und der afghanischen regierung gewünscht
die taliban bestehen weiterhin auf dem
abzug zum ersten mal wie es donald trump
geplant hatte
doch das spielt für die usa keine rolle
mehr sie sehen die ziele erfüllt
vor fast 20 jahren nachdem die usa am 11
september angegriffen wurden gingen wir
gemeinsam nach afghanistan
sicherzustellen dass afghanistan nicht
wieder zum zufluchtsort für terroristen
wird die einen von uns angreifen könnten
in afghanistan befürchten viele dass das
was erreicht wurde verloren gehen könnte
bildung für mädchen frauenrechte und
dass sich die ohnehin katastrophale
sicherheitslage weiter verschlechtert
das land könne ohne hilfe von außen noch
nicht allein gelassen werden denn die
afghanen wagen nicht gegeneinander zu
kämpfen wenn us truppen hier sind die
anwesenheit fremder truppen wird wie ein
schutzwall vor einem bürgerkrieg
in gut einer stunde wird sich auch us
präsident biden in washington zu den
abzugsplänen äußern
fragen wir müssen unseren
korrespondenten vor ort warum will der
us-präsident so schnell raus aus
afghanistan
ich glaube es ist die einsicht dass es
einfach keine idealen bedingungen für
einen truppenabzug geben kann angesichts
seiner regierung in kabul die bei den
beratungen in den letzten wochen sich
auch wenig kompromissbereit gezeigt hat
angesichts der taliban die wieder auf
dem vormarsch sind und deswegen wird der
präsident gleich in seiner rede wohl
sagen stadt wieder in einen krieg zu
ziehen gegen die taliban muss amerika
sich konzentrieren auf die
herausforderungen von denen abhängig ist
welche stellung welche welchen einfluss
die usa in der welt haben das wird er
sagen er meint damit natürlich allen
voran china als herausforderung dass er
militärisch massiv aufrüstet das im
pazifik mit den säbeln rasseln und
deswegen zieht man sich aus afghanistan
zurück man wird weiter militärhilfe
geben mögliche friedensverhandlungen
werden künftig dann bei den vereinten
nationen stattfinden und wenn es eine
größere terrorgefahr wieder geben sollte
dann wollen die usa mit drohnen und
luftangriffen reagieren
ob das wirklich dann funktioniert ich
glaube es ist ein großes risiko dessen
es sich joe biden auch bewusst dabei
wird gleich sagen es ist zeit für
amerika seinen längsten krieg zu beenden
live aus washington mrt wissen vielen
dank genau 20 jahre nach den
terroranschlägen in new york und
washington will us-präsident beiden
seine soldaten also endgültig aus
afghanistan abziehen
wichtige fakten rund um den truppenabzug
haben wir kurz und kompakt in der heute
app zusammen
fast zweites großes thema heute bei der
nato die sorge um den konflikt zwischen
russland und der ukraine
denn russland hat massiv truppen und
kriegsgerät an die grenze bewegt die
ostukrainischen gebiete donetsk und
lugansk werden seit knapp sieben jahren
von moskau treuen separatisten
kontrolliert trotz vereinbarter
waffenruhe sind die kämpfe zwischen
ihnen und der ukrainischen armee seit
zwei monaten wieder aufgeflammt
christian senn berichtet wirklich
eingefroren war der konflikt in der ost
ukraine nie aber plötzlich ist er wieder
ziemlich heiß geworden wir sind
unterwegs mit dem ukrainischen militär
in der nähe von bonn jetzt an der
frontlinie in der ost ukraine
auf der anderen seite des schützen
grabens lauern die prorussischen
rebellen trotz waffenruhe gab es allein
seit jahresbeginn mehr als 50 tote auf
beiden seiten
wir erhalten uns bereit entweder ist die
eskalation ein hirngespinst oder der
auftakt zu großen realen ereignissen
verglichen mit dem letzten jahr hat sich
die situation verschlechtert die sorge
ist groß dass der krieg im donbass
wieder aufflammt vor allem seitdem
russland sein militär mit panzern
geschützen und tausenden soldaten an der
grenze zur ukraine und auf der 2014
annektierten halbinsel krim
zusammengezogen hat satellitenbilder
sollen ein militärcamp in der russischen
region woronesch zeigen nahe der
ukrainischen grenze für die ukraine und
die nato eine gezielte provokation
putins moskau sagt was man auf
russischem boden mache gehe niemanden
etwas an us präsident biden hatte
gestern mit wladimir putin telefoniert
zur deeskalation aufgerufen und ein
treffen vorgeschlagen
das ist ein neuer vorschlag von seiten
der usa
er wird untersucht und analysiert bevor
die entscheidung getroffen wird
von wladimir putin heute kein kommentar
zu den ereignissen er sprach lieber
darüber dass er gerade die zweite corona
impfung bekommen habe an der frontlinie
sagen uns die soldaten bereite man sich
auf jedes mögliche szenario vor die
dritte krawallnacht in folge und der ruf
nach gerechtigkeit nach dem tod eines
afroamerikaners kommt die us stadt
minneapolis nicht zur ruhe
der 20-jährige down treibt war am
sonntag bei einer polizeikontrolle
erschossen worden
aus versehen wie es heißt ines trams
wieder proteste bis in die nacht vor dem
polizeihauptquartier von brooklands
center einem vorort von minneapolis
die ausgangssperre wird nicht
eingehalten die polizei setzt daraufhin
blendgranaten und tränengas ein
ich werde demonstrieren bis sie uns
gerechtigkeit geben bis sie was ändern
werde ich hier draußen sein
am sonntag war der 20-jährige don't
write bei einer fahrzeugkontrolle
erschossen worden
eine polizistin hatte wright vor dem
einsatz eines elektroschockers gewarnt
dann aber die echte waffe genutzt
angeblich aus versehen wieder ein junger
schwarzer tod die polizistin
zurückgetreten
reitz familie spricht von systemischen
rassismus bei der polizei glaubt nicht
dass es ein unfall war
sperrt sie ins gefängnis wie sie es mit
uns machen würden hätten wir das getan
würden wir in der zelle landen würden
sie nicht von versehen reden sondern von
mord währenddessen heizt der prozess um
den tod von george floyd unter dem knie
des weissen polizisten die rektorin die
proteste zusätzlich an
die verteidigung ist nun mit ihren
zeugen am zug ich denke der gewinn war
im recht er hat mit objektiver
angemessenheit gehandelt entsprechend
den leitlinien der minneapolis polizei
und aktueller standards der
strafverfolgung
die proteste werden wohl weitergehen
am mittag wird bekannt die polizistin im
fall don't write wird wegen totschlags
angeklagt nicht wegen mordes noch mal
nach deutschland corona hinterlässt auch
auf dem ausbildungsmarkt deutliche
spuren im vergangenen jahr wurden so
wenig lehrlings verträge geschlossen wie
seit der wiedervereinigung nicht mehr
fast zehn prozent weniger als im vorjahr
heißt es vom statistischen bundesamt
experten befürchten dass sich dadurch
der fachkräftemangel weiter verschärft
besserung sei erst mal nicht in sicht
schlechtes zeugnis für die eu sie seien
nach china der zweitgrößte zerstörer von
tropenholz so ein bericht der
umweltorganisation wwf innerhalb der eu
liege deutschland ganz vorn im schnitt
würden durch deutsche importe etwa von
rindfleisch kaffee und holzprodukten pro
jahr 43 1700 hektar wald vernichtet
bundesregierung und eu müssten für
verbindlichere umweltstandards im handel
sorgen fordert der wwf
und damit sind wir bei der
fußball-champions-league norbert der
titelverteidiger bayern münchen ist raus
macht selbst dir ja das war ja irgendwie
das war echt eine 95 minütige
fußballkrimi gestern abend im
viertelfinal rückspiel in paris der 1
0-sieg der bayern gegen psg reichte
nicht für das viel beschworene wunder an
der 10
jetzt geht es auch um die zukunft des
bayern trainers hansi flick sucht seinen
platz ein mindestens zwei deutliches
bild nach dem ausscheiden gestern die
vorjahresfinalisten lieferten sich ein
packendes duell auf augenhöhe bei dem
thema erst die latte dann den pfosten
traf fünf minuten vor der pause brachte
der lewandowski ersatz shooting den
titelverteidiger in führung
mit dem einzigen tor des abends wuchs
die hoffnung der münchner aufs
weiterkommen
doch auch bei seinem besten versuch in
der zweiten halbzeit hielten aber sektor
für die franzosen das halbfinale und für
die bayern die trainerdebatte fest dass
ich mir gedanken machen über meine
zukunft
ich glaube dass da hat jeder von ihnen
auch verständnis aber jetzt direkt namen
spiel muss erst mal das ausscheiden
verdauen
das dürfte nicht mehr lange dauern bis
die erste enttäuschung überwunden ist
und dann auch in dieser frage
licht ins dunkel kommt nach trainer adi
hütter wird nun auch sportvorstand fredi
bobic die eintracht im sommer wie
erwartet vorzeitig verlassen
und auch hier ist die nachfolgefrage
noch offen gestern hütter heute bobic
die kapitäne verlassen das schiff aber
bei den fans herrscht keine
untergangsstimmung ich habe ein verein
sich immer bewusst dass nicht größer als
der verein eintracht frankfurt ist und
wenn uns mit bobic jemand verlässt er
einst im pokal beschert und mit twitter
jemand verlässt der uns eventuell und
hoffentlich in die champions league
führt ich sag mal so uns haben schon
schlimmere leute verlassen dann ist es
halt so dann sollen sie weiterziehen
fredi bobic nach fünf erfolgreichen
jahren wohl richtung hauptstadt die
nachfolgersuche wird sicher nicht
einfach sportlich läuft es so gut wie
nie eintracht belegt sechs spieltage vor
schluss rang vier
im endeffekt ist einfach nur wichtig
dass jeder in die champions league kommt
und das wird er uns den schlüssel
übergibt mit der champions league weil
dann kann man sich in die augen sehen
danke sagen denn der österreicher hat in
kürzester zeit ein top team geformt das
jetzt die neuen verantwortlichen nach
der saison zusammenhalten müssen ja und
gerade eben wird gemeldet fredi bobic
wird neuer geschäftsführer bei hatte bis
sie vom wissen wir dass aus ihm wird
jedoch die lottozahlen sie lauten 2 4 18
19 20 46 und die superzahl 5 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
das aprilwetter geht morgen munter
weiter die details hat gleich aus dem
termin viertel vor zehn ist seit heute
journal mit bettina schausten im
gespräch mit gesundheitsminister jens
spahn
danke für ihr interesse machen sie sich
noch einen schönen abend tschüss und
muss morgen wenn sie würden schönen
guten abend und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter streuselkuchen artige bewölkung
so nennt der meteorologe diese wirkung
wenn man sie auf dem satellitenbild
sieht und dass es ein indikator dafür
dass dort kaltluft kommt und dann wird
instabil mit schauern und auch mal
gewittern
wir schauen die nachts da verschwindet
der streuselkuchen nur ganz im süden
gibt es einige schneeflocken ansonsten
klar des aufgangs im westen bildet sich
nebel mit tiefsten temperaturen von
minus sechs grad in den südlichen
landesteilen 2 grad im nordwesten
dort ist es frostfrei aber ansonsten
häufig mindestens leichter frost morgen
im tagesverlauf bildet sich erneut
bewölkung und dann gibt es schauer
teilweise mit regen und schnee gewitter
im südwesten sind gut durchaus möglich
nach norden hin bleibt es trocken und
das mit höchsten temperaturen von 4 grad
im vogtland und der höchste wert morgen
im südwesten mit 12 grad
schauen wir auf die nächsten tage am
freitag gibt es von westen her teilweise
regen und schnee viel wird es nicht sein
sonst lockert es im norden auf bei fünf
bis zwölf grad ähnliche verhältnisse am
samstag und am sonntag geht die
temperatur ganz zaghaft nach oben damit
ein schöner abend